lourdes tiene dos billetes de un dólar
muy bien así que vamos a vamos a ir
contando cuántos dólares tiene tiene dos
billetes de un dólar aquí tenemos uno y
tenemos otro muy bien además dice que
tiene un billete de cinco dólares tiene
un billete de cinco dólares así que
podríamos sumarle su billete de cinco
dólares y también nos dice que tiene
tres billetes de 10 dólares ok digamos
que aquí está el primero aquí está el
segundo y aquí está el tercero la
pregunta es cuánto dinero tiene en total
muy bien vamos a tratar de hacer estas
operaciones muy bien podríamos por
ejemplo sumar estos tres números primero
tenemos 1 más 1 nos da 2 y si después le
sumamos 5 nos da 7 verdad uno más uno es
22 más cinco es 7 ahora qué pasa si
nosotros sumamos estos tres números que
tenemos en morado
tenemos 10 + 10 + 10 eso es 30 verdad 10
+ 10 son 20 20 10 son 30 ahora bien
tenemos que sumar estos dos números que
acabamos de obtener cuántos serán siete
unidades más tres decenas o lo que es lo
mismo siete más treinta pues nos da un
total de 37 verdad y por supuesto
estamos hablando de los dólares que
tiene lourdes vamos a hacer otro
ejercicio dice irina tiene seis billetes
de un dólar tiene seis billetes de un
dólar así que de hecho voy a tratar de
dibujar esos billetes aquí tenemos un
billete de un dólar tenemos bueno no sé
creo que siempre tienen la cara de
alguien importante
y billetes
en la carita por supuesto 4
muy bien
seis billetes de
y un dólar y no sé qué personaje famoso
se encuentre en los billetes de un dólar
pero generalmente hay un personaje
famoso verdad y algún personaje de la
historia luego nos dice que tiene
también tres billetes de cinco dólares
tiene tres billetes de cinco dólares
digamos aquí está el primer billete de
cinco dólares quizás tenga otro
personaje famoso aquí está el segundo
billete
ok de 5 dólares ok y el tercer billete
aquí está nuestro tercer billete de 5
dólares y finalmente nos dice que tiene
un billete de 10 dólares muy bien aquí
tendremos un billete de 10 dólares venid
a lo mejor no sea yo hay otra imagen
quién sabe
entonces la pregunta es cuánto dinero
tiene en total
entonces si nos ponemos a pensar por
ejemplo cuánto equivale en seis billetes
de un dólar pues tendremos uno dos tres
cuatro cinco seis dólares verdad
ahora bien nosotros tenemos tres
billetes de cinco dólares esos son cinco
diez quince dólares y finalmente lo que
tenemos que hacer es sumar el billete de
diez dólares entonces la pregunta es
cuántas seis más quince más diez y bueno
podríamos ver que 6 más 15 nos da 21 y
si después le sumamos 10 nos dan un
total de 31 dólares quizás también lo
que pudiste haber hecho fue hacer lo
siguiente tienes 15 y le podemos sumar a
puede ser uno se poder sumar 10 y
después sumar 6 verdad sumamos 6 y
tenemos 60 es 65 son 11 y llevamos una
decena así que tenemos 123 decenas y nos
da 31